if you blinked this week you might have
missed all four of the developments
we're going to investigate today from
open ai's flip-flop on whether to
maximize engagement to doubts at the top
of that company as to whether they
should even be building super
intelligence and from the heating up of
the battle to control quality data and
the share of what samman calls the1
trillion AI future to this the startling
findings from the biggest survey of AI
researchers today I'll cover the
highlights of this 38 page paper but
let's start with something I noticed
about the GPT store that's the store
basically where you can create your own
version of chat gbt based on your own
data your own custom instructions that
kind of thing various companies are
getting involved and creating their own
GPT and I'll talk about some of the gpts
that I've looked at but it was actually
this short paragraph in the announcement
of the GPT store that I want to focus on
first it might seem like a small deal
now but in a few months or at the latest
a few years this short paragraph could
have major ramifications in the
paragraph open AI are describing the
opportunity for Builders to create their
own gpts and what they'll get out of it
basically how can builders monetize
those gpts that they're creating well it
seems like the way that open AI want to
monetize their gpts is through
engagement here's the key sentence as a
first step uson Builders will be paid
based on user engagement with their gpts
in other words get your users to use
your GPT as much as possible for as long
as possible and you'll probably thinking
okay philli what's the big deal with
that sentence well here's samman
testifying before Congress mid last year
companies whose revenues depend upon
volume of use screen time intensity of
use design these systems in order to
maximize the engagement of all users
including children with perverse results
in many cases and what I would would
humbly advise you is that you get way
ahead of this issue first of all I think
we try to Design Systems uh that do not
maximize for engagement in fact we're so
short on gpus uh the less people use our
products the better um but we're not an
Advertising based model we're not trying
to get people to use it more and more so
what might explain this flip-flop well I
think it's character AI their platform
full of addictive chatbots is apparently
catching up to chat GPT in the US as of
just a few months ago they had 4.2
million monthly active users in the US
compared to 6 million monthly active us
users for chat gpt's mobile apps it's
also well known that people spend longer
with character AI than they do on chat
GPT there's also of course competition
from inflection AI who have their Pi
personal intelligence it's basically a
chatbot that kind of wants to be your
friend and it's soon going to be powered
by inflection 2 their most powerful llm
then there's me is Universe of
characters where you can quote chat to
your favorite celebrity via a chatbot so
that commitment not to maximize
engagement does seem to be waning indeed
when samman had fun speculation about
what gpts will be doing the best by the
end of today he had his own Theory there
are incredibly useful gpts in the store
but probably everything is wuss runs
away with it I'm not too familiar with
that but I believe it's like AI
boyfriends and AI girlfriends just
before we move on from the GPT store
there's an experience that happened to
me quite a few times I would test out
one of the gpts like right for me and
that GPT says it can do relevant and
precise word counts I tried multiple
times and every time it failed on word
counts I'm not trying to pick on one GPT
but very often using one of the gpts
wasn't really an improvement on just
using GPT 4 there was however one
notable exception to that which was the
consensus GPT obviously this is not
sponsored but by giving relevant links
that I could then follow up with it was
genuinely helpful and better than GPT 4
Bas this is for the specific task of
looking up scientific research on a
given topic but now I'm going to give
you a little dose of nostalgia we are
almost a year to the day when I started
AI explained and one of my very first
videos in that week was a review of the
original consensus app that video is
unlisted now cuz it's simply not
relevant anymore but I do talk about the
one-year anniversary of the channel and
how it's changed on my latest podcast
episode on AI insiders for patreon
there's even a link to the unlisted
video if you want to see what AI
explained was like back in the day but
there was a much more cryptic
announcement from open AI at the same
time as the GPT store that I'm not sure
was fully intentional the reason I say
that is that it was leaked SL announced
by someone not from open aai it seems a
bit like an inadvertent launch because a
few minutes later Greg Brockman put out
out a hastily written tweet which he
then edited into this tweet Greg Rockman
is the president and co-founder of open
AI the update was about GPT 4 learning
from your chats carrying what it learns
between chats and improving over time by
remembering details and preferences
you're then allowed to reset your gpt's
memory or turn off this feature but I
don't know about you but it reminds me
directly of my previous video on what
Mamba would allow if you're curious
about that architecture or selective
State space models then check out that
video but the point for this video is
this we don't know if this announcement
was intentional and we don't know what
powers it it could of course just be
storing your conversations to load into
the context window but it feels more
significant than that as Brockman says
they are still experimenting but hoping
to roll this out more broadly over
upcoming weeks and as the investor
Daniel Gro says it's the early signs of
a moe more significant than compute
flops he shared this screenshot where
you can ask GPT what do you know about
me where did we leave off on my last
project and remember that I like concise
responses so why would that be a Moote
well just like we saw with user
engagement for gpts it makes models more
addictive more customized to you why go
to a different AI Model A different llm
if this one from chat knows who you are
knows what you like knows what projects
you like to work on what code style you
use or more controversially feels a bit
more like your friend remembers your
birthday that kind of thing if you think
that's farfetched by the way remember
that photo realistic video avatars are
coming as well soon and of course The
Natural end point of this is that these
chat Bots become as intelligent or more
intelligent than you after all that's
what open AI have said that they're
working towards all along they want to
build super intelligence the super
meaning beyond beyond human intelligence
in this fairly recent interview with the
financial times Sam wman said he splits
his time between researching how to
build super intelligence and ways to
build up the computing power to do so
also on his checklist is to figure out
how to make it safe and figure out the
benefits and I promise I'm getting to a
point soon enough here but open AI have
also said that they admit that by
building AGI and super intelligence it's
going to replace human work indeed their
definition of AGI on their website is a
system that outperforms humans at most
economically valuable work and that's
just AGI remember not even super
intelligence indeed in a blog post on
super intelligence Sam wman and Greg
Brockman said that we believe it would
be actually risky and difficult to stop
the creation of superintelligence yes it
might automate human labor but the
upsides are so tremendous in quotes and
so many people are racing to build it
it's inherently part of the
technological path that we are on now
you are probably really wondering why
I'm bringing up these recent quotes to
recap they're building super
intelligence they have to build super
intelligence and yes it will mean the
automation of human labor well here's
why I bring all of that up it seems like
there might be the first inkling of
second thoughts about that plan just 4
days ago one of the key figures at open
aai Andre karpathy said this he says
that the best possible thing that we can
be is not eak or EA but all about
intelligence amplification in other
words we should not seek to build
superintelligent Godlike entities that
replaces humans so that's no super
intelligence and not for the replacement
of humans it's about tools being the
bicycle for the Mind things that Empower
All Humans not just a top percentile and
it's pretty hard to disagree with that
it seems like a wonderful Vision to me
too but it was quite fascinating to see
Sam Alman retweet or repost that tweet
the obvious questions are like are you
trying to build two super intelligence
or are you not are you trying to replace
human labor or are you not trying to do
so you can't keep describing your latest
advancements as tools but then admit
that they are going to replace human
labor and eventually be more intelligent
than all of us I mean I do think almost
everyone could get behind this vision
from Andre karpathy it just seems to
contradict some of the other stuff that
open AI have put out also if I had a
chance to ask karpathy or Alman I would
say how do you draw the line between a
tool and something that replaces us
making an AI model more intelligent
indeed makes it a better tool but it
also makes us one step closer to being
replaced in the labor market giving an
AI more agency and Independence will
make it a better assistant but again
makes it one step closer to being able
to replace your job Indeed as another
key worker at open aai said Richard no
he thinks we'll continue hearing that
llms are just tools and lack any
intentions or goals until well after
it's clearly false I guess I'm seeking
Clarity on what divides something from
being a tool and being a replacement and
if open AI are trying to be on the same
page on this they need to State clearly
what that dividing line is now just
quickly before we get to that AI
researcher prediction paper there's one
more thing from open AI that I find hard
to reconcile last month they did a deal
with Axel Springer a Publishing House to
create new Financial opportunities that
support a sustainable future for
journalism and as of two days ago it was
revealed that they're in talks with CNN
Fox and time to get more content and
finally the information revealed what
open aai is typically offering
Publishers it's between 1 million to $5
million annually and what we also
learned from this article is that battle
to control data is not just being waged
by open aai or even open aai and Google
Apple has actually launched into the fry
and they are trying to strike deals with
Publishers for the use of their content
but the difference with apple is that
they want to be able to use content for
future AI products in any way the
company deems necessary that could
include for example imitating the style
of a particular publisher or journal or
for example developing a model that acts
as the world's newspaper remember you
can customize models now so you can have
your own Fox News your own MSNBC you
could have for example your own person
personalized AI video Avatar giving you
exactly and only the news that you want
what that does to society is a question
for another day but Apple are apparently
offering up to 50 million for those kind
of Rights so what so hard to reconcile
then well remember this is all about
creating new Financial opportunities
that support a sustainable future for
journalism but Sam Alman has already
said that his Grand idea is that open AI
will capture much of the world's wealth
through the creation of AGI and then
redistribute this wealth and he's talked
about figures like $1 trillion and 100
trillion in a world where open aai
Google and apple are creating aund
trillion dollar worth of wealth and
profit seems like in that world they
would have gobbled up independent
journalism or at least the major profit
of independent journalism indeed $1
trillion is about the size of the entire
Global GDP and that kind of makes sense
right if GI or superintelligence can do
the task of any human being it would
make sense to equate it with the global
economy size how that fits in with a
sustainable future for journalism I'll
have to work that one out but it's time
at last for AI researchers to weigh in
themselves on all of these debates
thousands of AI authors submitted their
predictions for this paper it's
predictions about everything timelines
safety economic impact everything and of
course as you might expect I've read the
paper in full and I'm going to give you
only the most juicy bits this paper by
the way came out just a week ago but
let's start with the very first
paragraph these results by the way come
from a survey of
2778 AI researchers so here's the first
prediction if science continues
undisrupted the chance of uned machines
outperforming humans in every possible
task was estimated at 10% by 2027 and
yes at 50% by 2014 47 but let's focus on
that 10% by 2027 that's a one in 10
chance that all human tasks are
potentially automatable in 3 years from
now now there is one quick caveat that
I'm going to add to that on behalf of
the paper even if there is one model out
there that can wire a house and solve a
math competition doesn't mean that
there's instantly billions of such
models if we're taking embodiment into
account the mass manufacturing of all of
those models would take a lot longer
than just a few months or years but
nevertheless if you sit back and just
read that prediction again from AI
researchers like it's easy to get lost
in the noise and the news and next week
there's going to be another model
another development but a 10% chance in
three maybe three and a bit years for
every human task to be potentially
automatable did is pretty insane these
estimates as they say are typically
earlier than they were when these
researchers were surveyed last year now
you may have noticed that this sentence
uses the word outperforming and there's
a later sentence in the first paragraph
talking about being fully automatable
and I'll come back to that in a moment
and when I say a moment I mean like
literally right now because in the paper
there was an incredibly Stark and
unjustified difference between the
predictions for highlevel machine
intelligence that's all human tasks and
the full automation of Labor all human
jobs with the full automation of Labor
being predicted for the 2100s and of
course on hearing that many of you will
be like wait what's high level machine
intelligence then and all human tasks
well here is where they describe
highlevel machine intelligence as
defined for this survey high level
machine intelligence is achieved when
uned machines can accomplish every task
every task better and more cheaply than
and human workers so not just better but
also more cheaply think feasibility not
adoption the only caveat is that we're
assuming here that human scientific
activity continues without major
negative disruption but the date by
which there is apparently a 50% chance
of this happening is
2047 down 13 years from 2060 but how on
Earth would it take us from 2047 to the
2100s to go from a machine that can
accomplish every human task better and
more cheaply to the full automation of
Labor like literally how long do they
think it's going to take to manufacture
these robots and don't forget the
manufacturing of these embodied AIS is
going to be assisted presumably by the
high level machine intelligences it's
not like manufacturing is going to
continue at the pace it always has each
Factory would have its own AGI helping
it speed up production to be honest the
main result of this survey for me is
that it shows that AI researchers are
really not good at thinking through
their predictions later on in the paper
the authors admit that this discrepancy
between human level machine intelligence
and the full automation of all labor is
surprising and their guesses are maybe
it was the framing effect of the
question or maybe it's that caveat about
the continuation of scientific progress
maybe respondents expect major
disruption to Scientific progress and
there's something else from the paper
that I found kind of amusing what is the
last job that AI researchers think will
be fully automated being an AI
researcher that's at 2063 of course
that's the 50% prediction some people
think much earlier some people think
much later now number one I think that's
kind of funny that AI researchers think
what they do is going to be harder to
automate than anything else but number
two look at the Timeline 2063 that's 40
years or so from now but now think back
to open AI who have the goal of solving
super intelligent alignment in four
years and the key point is this their
method of doing so is to automate
machine learning Safety Research that's
right build an AI that can do the Safety
Research for them indeed one of the
things they're working on is trying to
align the model that's going to solve
alignment but the point is look at their
timeline they think it's possible indeed
it's their goal to create this automated
alignment AI researcher in four years
they call it the first automated
alignment researcher now yes it's quite
possible that they miss this deadline
and it takes 5 years or 10 years or
maybe they do it faster than 4 years but
look at the kind of numbers we're
talking about 4 years 5 years 10 years
now I get that alignment research isn't
all of AI research and there's a lot
more there but these 4E 5e 10e goals
seem a big stretch from a 40-year
expectation of the automation of AI
research one of these two dates is going
to be pretty dramatically wrong now for
a few more interesting little highlights
before we close out the paper found that
subtle differences in the way that they
ask certain questions radically change
the results apparently if you ask people
in this kind of way will we have super
intelligence by 2050 you get much more
conservative answers than if you ask
give me the Year by which we'll have a
50% chance of super intelligence in a
related study when people were asked
about the chances of AI going wrong when
they were asked for a percentage they
said 5% when they were asked for for a
fraction it was one in 15 million now of
course these weren't the same people
otherwise they'd be pretty bad at
mathematics these were different test
groups given different versions of
questions one tranch of the researchers
might get one style of question another
tranch gets a different style but I
guess the take-home here is that human
psychology and anchoring is still
playing an immense role when we talk
about timelines and predictions here's
another fascinating highlight the
researchers were asked about the
possibility of an intelligence explosion
this is the question some people have
argued the following if AI systems do
nearly all research and development
improvements in AI will accelerate the
pace of technological progress including
further progress in AI over a short
period less than 5 years this feedback
loop could cause technological progress
to become more than an order of
magnitude faster that's a period of less
than 5 years in which technological
progress becomes 10 times or more or
faster now before you see the results
let's reflect that would be a crazy
world it's already hard to keep up with
AI and I say that as someone who does it
for a living now imagine research and
progress being 10 times or more faster
so is it 5% or 10% of AI researchers who
think that's possible no it's a majority
of respondents in 2023 it's 24% who
think there's an even chance of that
happening 20% who think it's likely and
9% % who think it's quite likely that's
53% of AI researchers who think will get
this accelerating feedback loop a Proto
Singularity if you like at that point it
would almost be worth live streaming my
channel rather than creating videos
because it would like every minute
there's a new bit of news apparently 86%
of the researchers and I would phrase it
as only 86% were worried about deep
fakes to count by the way they had to
view it as at least a substantial
concern I would show those guys this in
January of 2024 these were made in
blender and Cinema 4D but they look
ridiculously lifelike to me if 14% of
researchers don't think that deep fakes
will be at least a concern I don't know
what to say to them and the vast
majority of respondents 70% thought that
AI Safety Research should be prioritized
more than it currently is and an equally
clear message is that timelines are
getting shorter the red line is this
predictions and the blue line is last
year's and the lines being more to the
left mean more proximate more close at
hand predictions this is for human level
machine intelligence now I made a
detailed AGI timeline of my own for AI
insiders but suffice to say I am well to
the left of that red line and just one
final point before we leave this survey
some people I am sure in the comments
will point out that it only achieved a
15% response rate similar to previous
years thing is they even gave prizes for
people to respond to the survey so they
tried their best it seems that most
people just seem to not want to spend
the time to answer surveys and to be
honest I can understand and that
response rate is in line with other
surveys of a similar size but I can't
end on that technicality in the week of
CES 2024 in Las Vegas now I can talk
about more of my highlights if you like
but there's one device that stood out to
me it's ridiculously expensive but shows
AI can be insanely useful and fun when
we want it to be it's these almost five
grand AI powered binoculars that can
identify birds while you're looking
through them I just think that's insane
and super fun and I'd get it if you
dropped off a couple of zeros anyway we
have covered a lot in this video I am
really curious to hear what you think
thank you so much for watching and have
a wonderful day